[Music]
the wind the past few weeks
[Music]
keeping me awake every night
the thunder of paths getting in
i suppose every house around here has
the same ghosts
[Music]
i wonder how they tell them all about if
they came back
[Music]
do you reckon
mother knows
it's exactly like it was back in the day
so long ago i wouldn't get hung up on to
fire you
try to leave a place
don't need to find a thought away
it's brining
[Music]
there's been a claim made by a young
woman
ryan says he was at home with you that
night
is that right
he was here we both know that's a lie
though
this a serious accusation
you don't want to hear her side
you laughed at oliver about how long
usual family groups boys being boys
was there anyone else out do you
remember
i couldn't tell you everyone's got their
eyes closed
who do you think i am at all man
do you not hear anything about what's
happening
is there no feeling in you
you have this impossible image of me
seems like the whole world is turned
upside down
you